[Music]
hey what is up guys MTV HD here and in
front of me I have two phones the iPhone
7 plus and the iPhone 7 and I don't do
that many live unboxing style videos
every year but this is definitely one of
them and you'll notice I have the matte
black iPhone 7 plus and the jet black so
the super glossy iPhone 7 so I'm going
to take a look at both of these and will
actually compare them and hopefully get
a better idea of which one you might
want to get if you're considering one of
the two new colors yea this is the
retail box experience and this is
exactly we're going to get if you buy an
iPhone 7 so they're both 256 CI phones
let's go ahead and open the boxes we'll
start with the glossy black we'll start
with the jet black iPhone you notice
it's a black box if you buy a jet black
iPhone you'll get one of those rare
black Apple boxes and we're off the bat
you don't get the phone at the top you
get the design by Apple in California
paperwork and then there is the iPhone
and all is glossy glory and the plastic
on the screen protector and that is
about as fingerprint free as this iPhone
will ever be but the hair it is then put
this on the side and see what we get in
the box number one you get your ear pods
not air pods these are your Lightning
attached earbuds well first of all
here's your dongle your adapter this is
your lightning two three-and-a-half
millimeter headphone jack adapter and
it's nine dollars if you lose this but
it's sold in the Apple Store and then
yeah these are your Lightning earbuds
you can see what the Lightning connector
right there you will get a lightning
cable to connect your computer connect
iTunes if you ever decide to do that and
your wall adapter so let's go ahead and
move on and get the matte black iPhone
out the box is I feel like it's going to
look very similar inside but let's go
ahead and make sure so again no phone at
the top paperwork move that to the side
and you get the iPhone
so Matt black obviously looks super
clean as well this is a phone that is
going to show fingerprints to but not in
quite the same way as the super glossy
iPhone on a larger phone side you do
have the dual cameras on the back that
we showed in that first hands-on video
and then of course if you compare it to
another bigger phone like say the galaxy
s7 edge you'll notice it's it's still a
lot bigger because it carries that much
bigger bezel I'm gonna actually boot
this one up and see what we get as far
as iOS 10s first boot but yeah it's
still carrying a big ole forehead big
old chin the new capacitive home button
and I can confirm that when it's off it
doesn't move at all which is kind of
interesting sensations go ahead and boot
into iOS 10 and set it up for the first
time I speak English
hey Siri hey Siri
but okay so this is definitely a new
step it's telling me to meet the new
home button so obviously on the iPhone 7
you have the home button that does not
move it's just a piece of glass and it's
pressure-sensitive so when we get
started here we'll be able to choose how
much I guess pressure feedback or what
the taptic engine will feel when we
press it so 3 is a really firm click
response 2 is the default somewhere in
the middle the whole phone seems to be
vibrating still but it doesn't quite
replicate a normal press and then one is
really light that's almost like I don't
know if I'm pressing it or not so I'm
going to go all the way up to 3 so I
know when I'm pressing the button so
there we are in iOS 10 on the iPhone 7
and obviously a lot of the stuff you'll
see here is exactly the same as it would
be on any other phone that's running iOS
10 like my iPhone 6s but obviously on
the new chip a little bit faster a
little bit smoother and a little bit
more interesting with this new home
button setting a quick run-through
Geekbench 4 for kicks since this is the
new a 10 fusion chip and yes three
gigabytes of RAM confirmed for the
iPhone 7 plus and two gigabytes for the
iPhone 7 but yeah you can see the final
score is pretty great especially the
multi-core right up there actually above
Snapdragon 820 devices but yeah there
you have it that is your first look at
the iPhone 7 in your jet black and your
matte black and a good look at the
differences between them
honestly if you're having trouble
picking I would just go the safe route
with the matte black this is almost like
a special edition phone at this point if
you haven't seen it in person
check it out in a store you're gonna see
the fingerprints and the scratches and
things like that but yeah that's that's
the unboxing experience and that's what
comes in the box and that's what you
will find if you order a new phone from
Apple this week either way that's been
it thanks for watching leave a thumbs up
if you want to see more unboxing stuff
like this in the future and I'll talk to
you guys in the next one peace
[Music]